this morning thousands of immigrants are
hoping to continue their Trek toward the
u.s. border from Central America their
Caravan is at the border separating
Guatemala with Mexico last night in
Arizona President Trump warned that the
caravan must be stopped before it
reaches the United States the president
of Honduras and Guatemala will meet
today to talk about returning the
migrants to Honduras chief chip Reid is
traveling with the president as in and
is in Phoenix chip good morning well
good morning one of the president's most
memorable promises during the
presidential campaign was to build that
wall on the Mexican border but so far
little progress has been made and polls
suggest the issue of immigration may
hurt his party's chances on Election Day
which is just two and a half weeks away
the Democrat Party is openly inviting
millions of illegal aliens to break our
laws violate our borders and overwhelm
our nation trying to fire up the
Republican base before the midterm
elections president Trump focused on
bashing Democrats Democrats produce mobs
Republicans produce jobs and changing
immigration laws we only are going to
let people in based on merit
after touring Luke Air Force Base in
Arizona the president harshly criticized
a caravan of migrants hoping to make
their way to the southern US border
these are hardened criminals he's a
tough tough people and I don't want them
in our country the migrants tore down a
fence in Guatemala but were blocked by
police at the Mexican border
the president's rhetoric denouncing
immigration does not appear to be
working in his favor
according to a recent CBS News poll only
39% of registered voters approve of mr.
Trump's handling of immigration at a
roundtable with Arizona Republican
Senate candidate martha mcsalley mr.
Trump once again stressed the importance
of a border wall and we need a wall we
have to have a wall we're building the
wall now but we should build it very
fast we should build it frankly we
should build it even
and while signing a presidential
memorandum he had a message for those in
the caravan they might as well turn back
they're not coming into this country
the president's Western Swing continues
today in Nevada we're like here in
Arizona a Republican candidate is locked
in a tight Senate race Anthony chip Reid
in Phoenix Thank You chip